the puja 108 is especially popular with
female drivers it comes as a three or
five-door hatchback and there are all
sorts of exterior paintwork and interior
choices if you shell out 1250 euros more
you can get a retractable fabric roof
that provides a nice breeze on a sunny
day test driver
eNOS Petrie says she's testing the
three-door version of the top
convertible she's especially interested
in how much space there is whichever
version of the 108 you go for the
dimensions are the same and there are
many reasons why this small french car
is a runner with women the paintwork can
be purple if desired the fabric roof can
be black gray or purple there's a makeup
mirror above the driver's seat but is
the car family-friendly
Athena says a modern woman has to juggle
various tasks in her daily routine
there are easel fix anchors on the back
seat to attach a child seat though it
might be a tight fit this would be
easier with four doors but the test car
only has three and that is often the
case in the real world too often people
buy these cars before they have kids and
then they have to adapt there isn't that
much extra space left over if the
driver's seat is pushed forward but it
is easy enough to install a child seat
Tina says that although you can put a
seat in it could get a bit fiddly to put
on seat belts she says people who are
thinking of using the car with kids
would be better off investing in two
extra doors the five-door version would
be more compatible with extra adults -
on the road the puja 108's performance
is very good it's capable of reaching a
maximum top speed of 170 km/h and
consumes 4.3 litres of gasoline per 100
kilometres this means
co2 emissions are kept below the 100
gram market the basic three door model
without a fabric roof cost less than
nine thousand euros in Germany
EDA says that the Peugeot 108 only
offers three cylinder engines this one
has 60 kilowatts that's more than enough
for city driving you can keep up with
the traffic and never get a feeling of
falling behind the 108 is very modern
when it comes to communications
she says the white interior reminds her
of modern tablet computers and the
technology in the car is just as modern
you could connect your phone to the cars
display and navigate via the phone for
example but if you haven't planned the
route in advance it consumes a lot of
data that's why young drivers might want
to resort to a traditional navigation
system
if a car is shorter than three and a
half meters long
you can't expect that much from the
trunk but this one is fine for shopping
in town possum you can fold down the
rear seats for more story space a total
of 780 liters if you have a child and a
bit more stuff you might have to be
creative about how to use the space
available if there's a child seat in
place you can only pull down one
backseat there's space for the shopping
but you might be a bit hard pressed if
you also wanted to fit in a buggy the
five-door hatchback might not provide
any more space but when it comes to
comfort and convenience it's definitely
worth shelling out the extra 450 euros
you